fun in life you don't have no fun in
life to meet you on my name is Roland
good to meet you I'm 20 years old and
smile at you in college I'm just trying
to figure out what's next I guess your
senior in high school do you know what
your major how the International Affairs
how did you go about choosing that well
that's what I love you're not a point
now where world is your oyster
you must stay positive it's your call
I thought I wanted to be in the nurse
because I wanted to help people and I
found out that it was not good fit for
me and so I wasted like two years and
some money I'm still learning so much
about myself there's so many things that
I like and so it's just like it's hard
to like narrow what you like
I love passion oh you dress to the nines
I love you out for that jacket is on the
move
Eames you could be excellent at that
yeah interviewing people about fashion
keep your mind open create your own
space in high school I'd enjoy taking my
typing class and I liked being organized
my friend suggested how about Claire
Kyle how about going into secretarial so
I went back to college changed my major
learn that and I had many happy years as
an administrative assistant also I
advise young people to talk to people
who know them really well whether it's a
best friend a boyfriend or girlfriend
and they'll probably have a very good
insight I was the only black person on
an all-white football team and I was the
quarterback and the captain Wow
so I took that discipline and all of
that stuff with me to UCLA in and had a
great time but I made my own rules even
calavius course and I was one of them
and it was just say and then on top of
me being like the gay and the openly gay
and
like you know it running definitely look
calorie there's a lot of a challenge but
I like intellectually spiritually and
passionately you were above it all yeah
that's how you were pull it off so yeah
I mean I'm about that age where I should
be starting to look for my partner in
crime I met my husband in college I just
liked so much about of course the big
test was to meet the family I'm the only
girl in the family so so protect very
protective so bad one over I pick oh gee
but I think when it's the right fit
she'll fit right in and they'll love him
like a son I mean they always say like
you know you I guess like you want what
you can't have or something I guess that
goes along those lines cuz like I feel
like I've been that too like but I was
always after the one that was just not
really I mean that's just my experience
you know like yeah that was just that
was like kind of like you know not
texting me back as much and just like
being whatever like you know short and
like because it was just more of it it
was like more intriguing that's always a
learning experience why do I want that
why can't I get it what's the best for
me sometimes you have to just let it
slide is my old grandmother you say do
without and keep on moving you know I
have just such a broad spectrum of
friends and we're very open with one
another
yeah be that way stay open keep the
lines of communication open always make
known your feelings yeah so there is no
confusion having raised four cents we
never had a lot of extra cash but we
always look for opportunities to have
fun watching the Sun rise over the
mountains or the sunset over the ocean a
kiss a hug a smile there's a lot of
beauty to be found in life and it
doesn't cost it
yes the worst regrets that I have heard
is people saying that they were too busy
chasing success or being a selfish with
their time that they didn't spend time
or take time for their families make me
want to call my parents that's good